hello everyone and welcome to what could
be the game of the year as some of you
have mentioned in the comments this is
the one of the most requested games from
round three it is American Grandmaster
Conrad Holt versus shakar mamar now I
don't know if we're considering U
formats other than the classical for
Game of the Year award uh but if so this
game definitely stands a chance so let's
check it out and why so many of you
recommended it like I said game three uh
round three Holt versus mmed yarov
Conrad opens with ped def four we have
Knight to F6 by shakar Pawn to C4 G6
Knight to C3 and pawn to D5 going for
sorry Pawn to D5 going for the
groomfield defense we have Pawn to E3 uh
Pawn to E6 and now C captures on D5
already an incredibly rare move there
are all only a couple of um games online
that were played in this exact
continuation so it is now as of move
five we can consider this to be a
completely new game and okay e captures
we have Bishop to D3 Bishop to G E7 and
Knight G to E2 better than developing
the Knight to F3 as you will also have
support um you know ability to support
E4 by playing F3 first we have castles
castles uh and now Pawn to A5 stopping
Pawn to B4 from White uh Bishop to D2
and now Rook to E8 we have Rook to C1 uh
and now uh Pawn to C6 so the center is
nicely defended we have Pawn to F3 uh
you have now support for E4 if needed
and pawn to B5 and here just Queen to E1
preparing to shift the queen over to the
king side uh and while you could Advance
the pawn to B4 doesn't really make all
that much sense since you free up the A4
Square for the Knight Knight B to D7 uh
we have Queen to F2 uh also have
additional support for the E3 pawn and
now Knight to B6 we have Pawn to A3 and
Knight to C4 and the Knight is um a
nuisance here to say the least so con
red eliminates at Knight Bishop captures
on C4 B cap R and now only now Knight to
A4 we have Rook to B8 and now Rook F to
E1 uh Pawn to H5 now comes Bishop to C3
the bishop also helps out with the
defense of the Pawn on on B2 and if you
execute E4 also the D4 Pawn will be
nicely defended uh Bishop to H6 putting
pressure on that E3 pawn and now conr
just moves the Knight so The Rook
supports the pawn as well uh Pawn to H4
kicks away the Knight Knight to F1 and
now even Pawn to H3 we have G3 and now
Knight to H7 uh making room for F5 to be
played so Knight to D2 uh and Knight G
Knight to G5 we have Pawn to E4 finally
executing that Central thrust and now D
captures on e4 F captures and pawn to F5
and okay uh we could say that chak there
is maybe uh opening up his King a bit
too much and that maybe his pieces
aren't really in the game uh but he
knows what he's doing and our good
friend the engine agrees with him the
engine rates this at maybe plus one plus
one and a half for black uh so Pawn to
D5 or makes sense to open up this
diagonal and now F captures an E4 we
have Queen to D4 now threatening Queen
to h8 and just King to H7 Now The Rook
guards the h8 square and now Pawn to
D6 and this is where things get really
interesting we have Rook to B5 Now The
Rook also gets to help out with the uh
with the the you know stuff happening on
the fifth rank also you can shift The
Rook over to F5 if needed but now Knight
to C5 gaining more control over that D7
square and here comes Bishop to F5 not
allowing the bishop to be uh you know
buried there on C8 but there was an even
better continuation here I'm just going
to show it because it's a lot of fun uh
E3 would have won the game for Shaker
point being that after you everything
gets traded off here you will capture
the pawn on D6 and now white really has
nothing for example Knight C uh Knight
ct4 you attack the queen you you go
after the Knight because you do have to
do something about the Knight that
Knight is hanging on C5 so let's see you
do this uh doesn't really matter Knight
captures also opens up an attack towards
the queen and after Queen captures you
will just pick up that bishop and okay
you do have some checks like Queen D7
check King to H6 Queen to f8 check you
will hide the King on H5 and if Queen h8
check you will just bring back the queen
and white cannot capture on C8 because
the Rook on C1 is also hanging so you'd
have to go back with something like
Queen C3 to defend the Rook but now
Bishop G4 and that's pretty much it not
much to be done here for white as white
is just down a full piece even if this
is captur like Queen E3 check King F1
Rook F1 check and white gets
checkmated uh so uh Pawn to E3 here just
winning for M but he went for Bishop to
F5 as this is a rapid game so you don't
have all that much time and now he
misses this wonderful G4 move and with
G4 you're forcing Bishop to capture and
if Bishop captures then Knight gets to
capture on e4 and then white is very
much back in the game so here Mido tried
E3 now but here E3 just doesn't work uh
D7 and now what do you play here well
the only move left is Bishop Capt on D7
or maybe you could go some Rook to E6
ideas but that just looks weird uh I'm
going to show it but it's uh Perpetual
at the most and if Knight captures on D7
e captures on D2 you have Knight to F6
check and now you will give up the queen
of course Queen captures D captures on
E1 uh Rook captures on E one Rook
captures on E1 and now Bishop captures
on E1 Bishop to G7 uh you attack the
queen and now just Queen captures on C6
of course see you cannot capture on G5
The Rook defends that and if you capture
on C6 now even Rook captures on B2 and
uh that's it black has all the drawing
chances in the world uh and even if uh
White makes a little misstep here it's
actually black who's playing for the win
here like you capture a pawn carelessly
here already Knight three check ends the
game like King F1 Knight captures an H2
check King G1 and now Rook to G2 with
check forces the king to H1 and now just
Knight F3 there's no defense against
Rook to G1 Checkmate so uh it it would
be possible if Bishop captures and D7
was played but here e captures on D2 was
played and now this is a problem look at
this D captures on E8 brings another
queen into the game and now uh Queen
captures an E8 was played and believe it
or not here Conrad has a forced
Checkmate in five so feel free to pause
the video and Checkmate mamedyarov in
five moves while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on not
being overly materialistic and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Rook to E7 check and this is one
of the reasons why as soon as I saw this
I thought about the the the game you
know uh Stein versus k f b
with the bravest rook in chess history
because here we have another such
example where the Rook continues
checking uh without the possibility of
capture because now if the Rook is
captured Queen to h8 is Checkmate so you
cannot capture you have to play Knight
to F7 but now Rook captures an F7 check
and again you cannot capture due to
Checkmate on a on h8 uh so King to G8
and now Rook to G7 with check again The
Rook cannot be captured due to Checkmate
so you're going to have to move the king
or you go to f8 but that's not much
better you allow Queen to F6 and now
Rook to E7 check with an Unstoppable
Checkmate King to G8 will be played and
now finally Queen to h8 will be
Checkmate but interestingly Conrad
doesn't find it he doesn't play Rook E7
check he plays Rook captures on E8 and
of course he's still threatening
Checkmate but now mamero finds a clean
way back into the game or you know he's
still going to be in a loss position but
it's still possible to get back into the
game he plays D captures on C1 brings
the queen in enter a game with check
King to F2 and now the problem is you
can't really continue checking whatever
you try you're just going to well let's
say try Queen C2 check just Rook back to
E2 defends and The Rook is back into the
game so here he finds Queen to G1 with
check uh King captures on G1 Knight to
F3 check wins back the queen so okay
King to F2 Knight captures on D4 but now
Bishop captur on D4 and again you cannot
get your Bishop to safety because
Checkmate is being threatened on h8 so
Bishop to G7 was played H but now Rook
to E7 again threatening the bishop so
your best uh option is not to capture
the pawn but it only leaves you down too
much material Bishop captures on G7 uh
Pawn to G5 okay there aren't already
there aren't really all that many great
discoveries as everything is on a light
Square so Bishop to D4 with check King
to G6 and King to G3 we have Bishop to
F5 shock they have tried playing a few
more moves but after Rook to G7 check
King H5 Rook to F7 attacking the bishop
Bishop G6 and Rook f8 Bishop to B1 was
played but now um Connor just played
King captures on H3 and he was in this
position on move 44 that Shah madaro
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here there there isn't
even a move you can try like everything
is completely tied up uh with the Knight
covering B7 and B3 and Rook covering
sorry and Rook covering B8 there's no
way of actually getting the Rook into
the game so here you're just stuck
basically moving the bishop back back
and forth and you allow white all the
moves that white wants to make before
deciding on how to win this game
basically white can win this game any
way white chooses to so yeah uh great
stuff by Conrad he it it was a bit risky
if mamaro played it correctly you know
you I wouldn't be able to to to pull
this off but such is the case with every
brilliancy you know in order for a
brilliancy to become possible uh imp an
imperfection has to be made in the
position uh so yeah that's the game I
hope you guys enjoy enjoyed it the
beautiful stuff by Conrad Holt here I
think this is the first time we feature
him on the channel and what a better way
to be featured than by crushing a former
2800 member Shak mov I would like to
thank Jack schroer SOA Isaac Davis
Martin G Papik and Timothy rosan for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it uh as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you all for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the F World rapid
Championship uh and checking up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day